-Look how beautiful
you look here
on the cover of "Elle"
right there.
Not bad.
Do you like doing --
Do you like doing the big photo
shoots and the covers and --
-Yeah, I mean,
I think it's always --
I'm always super grateful
to work with amazing people,
work with a magazine
like "Elle."
Obviously it's
a super-iconic magazine.
-Yeah.
-This shoot in particular
was really cool and really fun
'cause I got to work with
a lot of amazing women.
The stylist was a female.
The photographer was a female.
People that I've worked with
in the past
that I'm comfortable with,
that I know.
So it was a great time.
It was a great crew.
-It's fun.
Did you do any party tricks?
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
Well, I say this because
last time you were on our show,
you did something that was
the most amazing thing ever.
Everybody was talking about it.
You opened a beer bottle
with your teeth.
-Mm-hmm.
-It was the raddest thing ever.
Everyone was like -- You got
a double standing ovation.
It was really amazing.
-It was really fun.
And there's actually another
funny story behind this,
and that is
that last time I was here,
we did this little party trick
where I opened a Corona bottle
with my teeth.
And the next morning,
after the interview had aired,
I got a certain phone call
from a certain someone.
And it was a little like,
"Hey, how are you?
I saw you on 'Jimmy Fallon'
last night.
You were looking really good.
I loved that trick that you did.
I had no idea
that you can do that.
It was so cool."
Cut to I'm now married
to that certain someone.
-No. No!
-Yes.
-Is that right?
-So I feel like --
-Wait a sec.
What?
-I feel like Jimmy
gets a little credit
for helping re-spark romance.
-Thank you very much.
-Alright, yep. That is true.
That is true.
-You think I'd be invited
to the wedding.
Now, look, now --
Hey, now, now --
No, I'm joking.
I'm joking.
By the way, I know, 'cause I've
seen you with Justin many times.
And you guys
are so cute together.
Look at how gorgeous.
This is you on your wedding day.
Ooh la la.
[ Speaks French ]
Here's you and Justin.
Everyone gets to lick the groom.
Everyone --
-Well, not everyone
got to lick the groom.
-Not everyone.
I'm sorry. No.
It's so cool
to see you guys together,
and you really are magic
together, I got to say.
It's so fun to hang out
with you guys.
And I know I just saw you
when we did the hockey thing
with Justin.
-Yeah, which was very funny.
-Tell him thanks again for that.
He was great.
But there's a really cool, odd
history between you and Justin
that is almost unbelievable.
This is out of a movie,
but it's real life.
-Right.
-You met him back in 2009
when you were 13 years old
with your dad.
What went down?
How'd it happen?
-I know. Sounds like this weird
arranged-marriage situation.
-I know, yeah.
-We met because my dad, he
brought me to the "Today" show
when Justin performed there.
He was no more than 15, I think.
And when we were there --
-Were you a Belieber?
-To be honest --
this is the truth --
he was so new that I didn't
really know a lot about him yet.
-Yeah, that's right, the
"Today" show did have him
before he, like, blew up.
-Yeah, it was really
kind of before anything.
So I met him,
and his mom and my dad
kind of just connected
as friends,
and we invited them over
to our house the next day.
So him and his mom just
came over for family dinner
with me and my family.
-Look at this.
-And we went bowling.
That's me, yeah.
And what's funny is that in
this photo, I'm super awkward.
I had braces.
Like, nowhere was there
a thought that I was like,
"Yeah, he probably
has a crush on me."
Like, I did not --
That was not the case at all.
We were just -- I don't know --
just were hanging.
-And you're married now.
-That is my entire husband.
-Isn't that
the coolest story ever?
I love this. How cute.
You're so cute. Come on.
-It's ridiculous.